reindeer eating psychedelic mushrooms  many categories of deer dine on  psychedelic mushrooms  including moose and Caribou that's why  Joe Rogan loves to eat these [ __ ]  tripping ass all the time observers  report that after eating the fungi deer  often act drunk by running around  aimlessly as hell like I want to put my  tongue on that running right up to a  train  eating these mushrooms infuses the  caribou's urine with psychoactive agents  meaning that the urine can and is  consumed for a high humans have been  getting high forever damn you sound like  Joe for a second  it's true I mean humans have been  getting high forever I mean dude I want  some Caribou you  gotta find that